hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome to bendy in the dark Revival
I just want everyone to take a moment to
appreciate this intro screen
Lexi and cut to when it growls
well I guess it's not going to do it oh
and I just talked over when it did god
dammit
it's cool it's really nice and it's
polished that's what I was gonna say and
I was gonna be like I appreciate this
because I know in the past I've been
kind of critical about some things about
bendy and the ink machine or whatever
the other ones were called but this one
is very very cool very polished very
neat I like it a lot
there that that's what I'm talking about
that deep grooter will grow very cool I
like it a lot I'm a sucker for a good
title screen and this one is no
exception so
time to get into it I don't exactly know
where the story picks up because I don't
know where the story exactly left off I
know that we were trying to escape from
the Joey Drew Studios or whatever it was
that the in the universe name or both
they're always free to choose
to Life Is Ours did you want to believe
oh okay life is owes to believe but when
you step back
when you really look at where you've
been and the things you've done
your past will
to devour you
okay well
um
that's not in my experience my past
doesn't usually come to devour me except
late at night when I'm staying awake
thinking about all the embarrassing
things that I've done
I guess it does come back too
devour me after all
there you go little guy and only 800
more friends to go hmm getting through
tonight without some coffee probably
some downstairs
look I'm not much for twiddling my
fingers or any part of me but I feel
like this twiddling isn't exactly as
twaddling as you think it is
time for a little Adventure oh this is
going to be great isn't it I'm Audrey
apparently I'm an animator at this
wonderful establishment so I need some
coffee time for an adventure
archgate pictures that's not what it was
before though not something different
maybe it's the same I don't know
it looks roughly to be the same kind of
characters one now so I'm assuming it's
the same unless I wasn't
foreign
attention I was about to say they didn't
need to be the universe answering me
uh-huh
okay hey what's with these weird stains
I'm not gonna ask any questions about it
Nathan Arch
oh
this doesn't feel like an office that
most people would be working in I just
want to say this if this is the
navigation that I have to take to get
coffee then it seems like there's fire
hazards
foreign
that
[Music]
has a lot of things that are suspicious
in here but the door handles are pretty
much at the top of my list I don't trust
any place with door handles I can't
grasp
it's demon the demon what kind of demon
man you you use heavy
you got heavy
well I wouldn't knock you over because
it would be disgraceful
to this establishment which is built up
as a testament Testament to you can I
get at least a cola
a seven new Spritz root beer
or the censored one
all right
fine
I guess I'm getting through this what in
the hell are you
that took me a second but that was kind
of creepy but whatever I had an ejective
thing here right yeah I do
oh okay
here's the key oh good
hello it's me
all right sure
I couldn't have grabbed that beforehand
I wonder if I actually could have but
I'm not gonna restart the game and find
out
an alarm is a bad thing
or at least indicative of something that
should be an emergency ah well
whatever's probably fine
hello
coffee please
the hallway I've ever seen I'm sorry did
you not notice the mop that was floating
across the way because there's this
janitor playing hockey practicing
a weird curling sport thing it's not
weird I promise it's great
I swear
is someone there
um
that's a little too over the top in
terms of hauntings
maybe this is an homage to your game
lexian
they've heard of it they put it in this
game
was it late night mop Late Night clean
late night mop mop clean mop
I swear I remember and it was a very
good game and I really appreciate you
taking the time to give the effort but
just can't remember if it was a mop or a
late night sweetie
Late Night clean late night
mop
okay
definitely 100 hello
no
okie dokie
I have expected something to be in there
in this building full of cliches
now will something jump scare me
I knew you oh my god Wilson
you scared me to death I'm sorry my dear
didn't mean to frighten you really
you're working late tonight oh boy a
pretty girl like you
shouldn't be wandering around all by
yourself
mind if I
step in
uh of course not thank you
Audrey you have so many manners
company
I mean yeah you're right did that did
that accent and mannerisms come with the
eye or did was it all like were you born
that way
it's been really nice this past week pop
out the womb going
[Music]
what was that
just tell me we're not trapped in here
don't you worry my dear
it's just a little short in this system
happening a lot this past few days no
needs a friend
why would I fret ah the coffee floor
let's see what we can find
come along now
Old Wilson will protect you I actually
believe you 100 that you're completely
innocent because no villain would be
this over the top in terms of uh actual
Menace or malice or menalis
should I step into the hallway of
Darkness or are you going to turn on
allow go into the hallway of Darkness
no I'm not
oh you need me to talk to you
well Wilson
have you fixed the fuse oh
there we are
just a few more switches to throw
follow me yeah I don't mean to be
perfectly
[Music]
okay yeah I don't mean to be rude but
did you just [ __ ] yourself or was that
there beforehand and you didn't clean
that up because I know you're half blind
but I feel like you should be able to
discern that there are messes here
with which to clean
and I assume that that is your job
does every employee have to go through
the museum to get coffee because that is
uh
that definitely reinforces the company
values I'm sure
okay
silly Vision oh
specially formulated ink to be applied
by an artist working on magnifying table
adjustments action enhancements even
whole new characters to be added after
the cartoon has been photographed
interactive experience of where the
cartoons could be custom altered ah
I like silly Vision do you like silly
vision
[Applause]
is this the coffee machine
is it the archway of coffee what's the
deal looks like someone's been messing
with the exhibits
there should be something on each of
these pedestals
Audrey
sweet
Audrey do an old man a favor and go find
him
I'll tend to the power
yeah okay really I mean the more you
talk the more I think you're harmless
and I just think that you're an old man
uh I don't know why this is my job
though I'll take this because apparently
I'm going to need it to find these
pedestal items of course I would do this
who wouldn't do this action that I did
all right well uh I'll as uh goodbye
huh
hi
well I think this might be one of the
pedestal items probably is this another
one
hi
oh
aha
not gonna lie a little weird
oh the illusion of living
all right
fine by me hmm maybe that was all of
them maybe some of them were actually
still on there but probably not
um
please
interesting
hmm
oh the wrench is a part uh
I see
that makes a lot more sense in me
grabbing that willy-nilly but somehow I
knew that it was there because I'm
assuming I worked here before and that's
all part of the job
for some reason
um is apparently a cog wheel for the
last one I don't know what that means
but I guess I'll try to find it
now oh cogwheel
oh I feel like that should be there and
not on the pedestal why wait but wait it
just it's not like maybe I I'm just
doing what the janitor asked because it
was like put anything on the bed until
I'm like this is a thing I don't know
any better how would I know any better
yeah
I did it let me guess you coincidentally
did it at the same time
hi only one thing left to do
oh okay
I thought it was murder time
it is done it is done
don't fret
we're going home
stay back
to remain attention to these last words
because very soon
forget everything
let's go come find me Audrey
and I'll
show her best
I'll show you
that you
let's get people
what are you doing
uh-huh
okay well
I still think he's a good guy look he
talks weird he may have killed us
drowned Us in ink living ink from silly
vision
[Music]
but it would be just too obvious he's a
good guy
I think that this was all an illusion
this life we live here all an illusion
this is the real world apparently or
something like that I didn't think it
was a little strange but you know you
just sort of trust people you gotta go
through life you can't be cynical you
can't be not trusting everybody who
speaks in a raspy deep voice and hacks
and wheezes and with one horribly
scarred eye hi that was pretty cool
actually
hmm
what's wrong with my hands
[Music]
Wilson knows your purpose
what's happened to you
[Music]
did you just talk to yourself in the
third person or were you talking about
Wilson what do you mean Wilson relax the
man who killed the ink demon Wilson
knows your purpose right
was Wilson the character from the first
game or something or uh is there
something that I don't know about hello
every great Story begins in mystery
although things may be dark at the start
the truth will illuminate your way don't
be afraid of who you are fear only what
you may become and banish it away your
best pal
all right
who's crying
who's crying
why would you be crying this is happy
fun times
I hope it's laughing it's probably
laughing now that I think about it now
that I had time to dwell upon it
I'm missing ladder pieces
I think
I'm assuming that's what that's about oh
two grand Cohen accounting please inform
Mr Drew that despite his insistence that
the rumors of Joey Drew Studios going
bankrupt are untrue I want to remind him
that if his Studio does indeed fail all
equipment and experiments
produced through our partnership by
contract belonged to the Gent
Corporation we will reclaim these assets
forcibly if necessary Alan Gray
um okay
is that just poison great
anybody seen pieces of a ladder ladder
ladder anybody seen a ladder or ladder
pieces pieces of ladder ladder ladder
ladder it's not like a good climb beyond
that it's simply impossible there's no
way there would be no way how would
there be a way ladder or ladder ladder
aha yeah I'm still goopy apparently
it's probably a good thing it's gonna
make me powerful or something ladder
God I'm smart
incredible I'm a genius now I can
clearly climb it once I could not before
oh hello geez you think I was drowning
kittens the way these people are looking
at me I've never seen such a
disappointment in a person's eyes but
this is the way of things if management
can't pay their bills then the bank
takes the goodies back still it does
break me a bit knowing how much I love
them old cartoons this place used to
make oh well times change life moves on
tally Wester
telewester sounds like a prick
Telly Western whatever hello
it's good thing that Wilson knows my
purpose
111 days
[Music]
away
control oh
I asked just a little favor among you
there is a stranger a young lady
bring her to me
[Music]
okay all right so you you you rented the
ink demon in Twain you say oh hide am I
gonna have to hide
uh probably
Joey Jack and I have been wondering if
you could meet with us considering the
current situation we have been with you
for many years and we feel we have
contributed to the success of Bendy in
the past our interest is purely in
keeping this company strong we just want
to help however we can let's talk Sammy
Lawrence all right okay
I need some kind of a refresher on the
lore
because I simply do not remember much I
remember some I remember a lot of
goopiness
yeah this is familiar
The Familiar let's see and make it sound
like I can talk
and insert some actual speech in there
the ink drips that it do that it do bro
Darkness has spread through the studio
the reaching Shadows creep around you
something hungers for your corrupted
flesh it is close so very close it
strains to grab you choke you from
behind you will feel his breath upon
your neck it is close your best bow I
mean uh I don't know what to take of
this but I'm assuming that something is
going wait a minute
hold on a second
you tell me that there's something close
right here it's gonna wait a minute
hold on a second
well surprise surprise it's fine
there's nothing to worry about anyway
Serge
Don't Mind If I Do
gent parts so did gent take over the
studio
because of the
Bank
Telly Wester telewacker wow you are
hideous
you're hideous
oh
grotesque even the butcher gang wasn't
that from the first game did you is you
one of the things maybe Wilson is the
character from the first game and when I
went through a wallop and things that's
uh that's what it was maybe that's what
it was it might have been what it was
battery
baseball
apparently for some reason I picked up a
memory what do you mean memory whoa look
at me I'm awesome look at me I'm rad as
hell holy [ __ ] look at me all right cool
um baseball signed by the legendary Bud
Lewis this would make an exciting gift
for any Young baseball fan
any of you young Baseball fans out there
would you be excited to have this if not
then it's a lie and I can't trust it so
tell me if you are because that's really
going to dictate all of my future
actions
all right
we're quiet into an extraordinary life
last I heard he was staying in some crap
Department downtown you practically hear
the rats in the telephone when he called
me last April
despite of that old Joey sounded quite
happy when last we spoke more like the
excited awful young man I knew once upon
a time
well
Farewell My friend
what will become your Creations now
uh they'll probably go on a murderous
Rampage if I had any inclination of how
these things typically go but at least
he died happy and free probably
there are bars on these windows or else
I'd be able to escape
hello
interesting what would that sound be
because it's clear that I transitioned
into some ink Universe I'm not sure if
any of this would ever be real but
I'm not 100 sure
[ __ ] run what do I need to
Moors was that you boy but it sounds
like there's cars outside which would be
very strange
all right bro
why I just opened a box is that really
necessary
who's there
why are you so drippy
ah
oh a bird
wait a minute
what was over here who's drippy
hmm
oh is it not dripping is it Sparks did I
mistake electricity for water I must be
some kind of an idiot here what's in
here nothing
Barrel no trash can yes nothing
waste of time it's trash
all right I'm done I'm getting
light-headed from that God hello
as the winds are changing around here
I'm asking my me self Sean what are you
doing there's a whole world out there
places to see a family to spend me days
with this here job is just a job I'll
have others like it no worry there but
the important thing is we should
remember to live I think it's time I did
just that
life is for the living am I right
everybody I am right shut up if I'm
wrong which I'm not
hi you're big
ooh trash damn how about behind the
trash now I can't go back I can still
jump though can I get up here is there
any point up here anything of use up
here
gonna get over bars nope
okay oh
wait a minute what's that
hello
well there was no point to that all
right
let's be on my way stop wasting time
hello
oh no
turns out things are faulty in this
imagination land
what am I gonna do about that
it's got very much like Bioshock Vibes
right now which I do like I appreciate
that a lot it always did that was the
thing about this game
hey hey I was pontificating what am I
doing you're lucky I have reflexes of a
God all right I'm running and hiding I'm
not sure if this is a good idea I'm
pretty sure he'd be able to see me
idiot
okay he shot me
[Applause]
well uh apparently you can do nothing
about this why do you look like Wilson
with your eye like that well it looks
more like Abraham Lincoln but
well must be safe now
all right oh
all right oh there was something in
there I just didn't know I knew that was
there immediately because I reached in
and grabbed it
all right I wouldn't drink too much of
that if I were you it helps patch you up
but the aftertaste it's not so good all
right easy now I'm not gonna hurt you
don't come at me like this then don't
touch me
what are you
what is this horrible Place yeah I
remember my first day down here I know
it's scary
but you're actually pretty lucky the
machine could have turned you into a
Searcher you think that that thing that
attacked me no that's a piper
part of a gang so be careful I don't
understand any of this
I can't think
you'll catch on pretty quickly if you
can stay alive
lesson once Searchers don't have legs
and they tend to swarm
look it's not good to stay in one place
for too long around here keep moving and
stay close to the Shadows take my advice
head to the upper levels
safer there
can I come with you
you can't
sorry hmm I have a wolf
he doesn't care for strangers a wolf
like I said you'll catch on Boris good
luck you talking about boars eat again
yeah I hope so too who the hell you
didn't even give me a name
away
[Music]
okay I will
oh you'll know him when you see him
he likes to smile
and he kills anything that moves that
sounds like me
oh my God am I handing demon what's your
name
they call me Alice
not very fond of it that's how names
work
well Audrey
welcome to the studio
it sucks here this place is trash it is
awful
but thank you all right so uh that
answered very zero questions except for
the questions of so the machine
the ink machine if I'm to go by the name
of the original game is something that
turns people into archetypes of
characters and that's why there were
multiples of things before
hmm
so anyway there's some good jump scares
that they got me with they got me good
who is in there
hello
thank you around here it's just best to
say out of sight don't ever go running
into some place if you don't know what's
in there if you attack a problem head on
you're gonna find yourself in trouble
and that's just foolish you gotta watch
listen and when the time is right push
forward
Your Best Buy your best pal
whoever that is is that Wilson thanks
for the advice Wilson I really
appreciate that
a new terror is descended into our lives
this man named Wilson ever since our
world feels strained like a gray Beast
held in Chains the ink demon has been
seen in a long time many of us refuse to
believe he's really gone but what does
it matter down here we're all Sinners
Children of the machine all have the
demon in our Inky blood
cool I mean you know it doesn't seem
that terrible except for all the
terribleness but you know it's got to be
kind of cool at least maybe a little bit
of like appreciation for living in a
world of Perpetual dreams and or
nightmares
it's all the same it's all the same
probably anyway
at least I made a friend
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
no I can't I can't redo what I did in
the Stanley Parable again where I just
danced forever
assembly line it's up four years I don't
antenna start now yeah I got a corner my
little sippin canteen did not do get
fine double quota I ain't even done half
in months oh but they won't fire me no
sir place is big no no for everyone else
is doing
turn up my radio and put up my feet cut
the hole in my socks if I have a club
comes easy around here hey everybody
all right well I mean whatever man is he
teach their own if they can't catch on
then they don't know enough that's going
on around here to have expectations in
the first place if they don't understand
how their own productivity is occurring
then the people in charge don't actually
know how to make productivity occur and
therefore their uh their opinions and
whatever they can come down here and
work themselves if they feel like it so
I'm all about that I appreciate that
um why is there nothing ever in these
oh
mommy Sashay over here
I mean it's not a bad look like I'm
gonna be perfectly honest not a bad look
I'm pretty cool you know if I woke up
and I looked like this I'd be like well
I'm all right I guess this is how it's
going to be today and forever that's not
bad I don't it
hello
where is the toy man is that the guy who
I just heard from that was putting up
his feet and relaxing
action all cool
every time I come back to work they put
in even more than pointless gadgets at
last week uh they uh they built some
kind of I don't know electrical Towers
over in the animation alley this week
they added security codes for opening
doors
Works they think we do here anyways last
I checked we make toys and silly
cartoons
he's Fort Knox you know what I mean now
it's my job to look over these shipping
invoices and remember about your random
numbers yeah no freaking thank you
I'm just gonna I'm just gonna record the
door code here so we don't forget it all
right code is for four five
one
four five one
if uh Mr Drew or Mr Gray asks you didn't
hear it from me okay man that's a big
cold I don't know if I can remember it
it's a gold man hold on
I can't even count this High bro oh man
it doesn't even go to ten at least the
total numbers
there's a password for babies how long
would that take it is there even a zero
I don't think there's a zero so it's
five factorial possible combinations
five five four twenty times three is
sixty times two there's only 120
combinations that could possibly be
there you could just go there and spin
the dials and you'd get it eventually
instead of panicking oh God I did it
all the security
probably useful because probably gonna
be running screaming in them
hello tasty chips
why why keep them eat them that's what I
always say why save it
shave it hello
that's probably fine
he sees everything who's he
videos in all its misplaced admiration
was so eager to absorb the life's work
of that crooked Charlotte and Joey Drew
they didn't fully realize what they had
acquired
call it fate that I just happened to be
there on the loading dock that morning
when the delivery boys dropped one of
the grades it smashed open and inside
there was something truly special a
massive yellow steel and beautiful
rivets
kind of machine no one knew what it was
so the fools put it on display for all
to see
but I could tell that this cruel device
held
that could be mine
I don't know why there aren't subtitles
for the audio logs there should be but
apparently Wilson knows and I turned
around I turned around
and suddenly everything was gone
all right hello
I'm up here now
yeah you better be afraid yeah
I'm gonna kill you you turn around
I turn around in there anyway
um where am I going
bladder
there we go good good good very good
okay
that seems like a small enclosed space I
thought I was going to go somewhere but
apparently not
oh I'm gonna go hunt down that monster
you thought that you could get away from
me no
I'm coming for you maybe I'm the ink
demon
I like to smile I kill everything inside
hello
is this important it looks important
hahaha
[Laughter]
oh man
oh man
oh man
I didn't expect that I do also when I'm
going about my daily life I go into
museums and whatnot as soon as I see
something important ah I hope it makes
me stronger you never know everybody you
never know I guess I'll because I'm
going to be running more
I guess
oh man good and this gracious I love me
I am the best
all right ookies
hmm
not sure why that needed a animation
unless something was going to be put
behind me to startle me
eat him up
I ate it there really is no saving that
stuff
well I'm looking at the ceiling now
apparently
yeah you just gotta eat it in me hi
hello you better watch out it was me if
you'd have looked over here you would
have gotten a jump scare
um move
I need to move it good thing I'm so
strong
I'm done moving it
I did it I have a key for this
Andy Dandy even
unless there's something behind me
ah
bendy starface stuffed toy discontinued
interesting I don't know what that means
but it's limited edition so it's
probably a collectible
foreign
I don't think that's how Doors door but
what do I know there's an ink world
nice stool
what are these from
what are those from
why does it sound terrifying in here
hmm
always good when there's a heartbeat you
can hear
hello
gent Parts still don't know what to do
with that but it must be some kind of an
upgrade
oh yeah you better
yeah you better run
or I might just do that
how do I save how do I save
that wouldn't be it
would be it you wouldn't think it would
be it but that's it apparently
thanks for letting me save am I probably
going to die no no way not me I'm too
good
everyone knows that a happy work
environment needs a place where you can
sit back and enjoy something tasty I'm
Joey Drew and you're standing in our
grand expensive new employee break room
my company family always deserves the
best by partnering with Briar label and
tasty bins I'm able to provide the most
delicious treats at a very cheap cost to
our workers pull up a chair and Shout
out my friends
I mean that sounds pretty cool I still
don't know where the line between
reality and not that thing blur it all
seems to be one and the same here
I am so strong ah oh I thought I was
gonna I thought it was gonna blast
through that uh it's ambitious for my
strength I suppose hello oh eat
sure why not eat it up no saving
hmm
[Music]
doesn't matter how old you are yeah
an entire cow
is there any more I would eat that
battery casing did I eat it probably ate
it
something goopy in here
who's in there
who's gooping
somebody gooping all right so what was
the point of that besides stuffing my
gob
my gob is Thoroughly stuffed but I'm
curious why
I don't know why
um
Oh I thought that was something oh my
God that startled me
that nearly startled me okay well I've
eaten everything I possibly could I have
a funny feeling I probably should have
saved some of that food because in case
I got damaged and then I would come in
there and then I would eat but no that's
not how I roll
I eat everything inside instantaneously
who has pockets hey is that open now
that wasn't open before why is that open
now
hello no it's not open
how do I open you
oh
nope okay I probably need something to
Wing
foreign
I better save after all that food
[Music]
anybody in there
hmm
okay interesting
I don't have any means of combat so I'm
assuming that I have to hide the moment
I see something dangerous but some I
just don't want to I want to confront I
want to fight I want to eat
in that order those are the things that
I want to do
hmm ticket booth huh
I'll be with you in just a moment again
this looks very smashable bashable even
safe and sound gen card required
all right interesting a dream Supply oh
it's kind of hard uh because everything
is like the same color oh
it looks like he's having a bad day
[Applause]
[Laughter]
he's dead
says open
you know in no open
all right it must be occupied with that
guy
um
all right I'll do what it says I'll go
to the objective
oh no it needs a key locked again oh
that's never happened to me before break
the lock
oh God I hope I can
I'm ready for something different in my
career I've built steel companies from
the ground up dabbled in petroleum even
tried political office once that Nathan
Arch they used to say He's Got The Magic
Touch
I'm hungry for a bit of fun I think
something both the masses and I can
enjoy my son suggested movies open a
studio now I love a good film as much as
anyone but the magic of anime
now there's something special my old
friend Joey knew the Thrills of bringing
characters to life rest his soul maybe
it was a bit of elbow grease and a small
cash Investments I can resurrect the
past
maybe maybe literally
hide no yes gentle
management has come up with a new way to
reward us employees instead of paying
out bonuses or overtime they've started
handing out these little tokens that you
can spend in company vending machines
besides that these tokens ain't got
value of any kind obviously a lot of
people didn't like the idea but the best
part about the whole thing is that
within a week someone figured out how to
make fake tokens at fools the vending
machines we started calling the fake
ones slugs now I can't remember the last
time I've seen a real token around here
them slugs are everywhere probably
costing the studio a ton of money and
snacks alone thanks Hudson can I take
him please yes slugs for me
food instantly consume
or anything in that one no
uh gen parts
anything here oh
all right but I didn't get anything that
I can smash anything with it's gonna be
some
hmm
toolkit now it looks like I could but it
it don't
maybe it's gonna be a workbench that I
could eventually craft something with
but for right now no
hi hello hello Audrey I'm so glad you're
all right Alice
I think you and I have very different
definitions of all right where are you
in a Mason Department entrance I just
locked up tight
there's something in here Audrey find
that jet pipe now my mom shouldn't I
hide first what do you mean find the
Gent pipe what does gent pipe even mean
I don't even know what I'm scared of
something what am I oh hi what in the
hell are you you'll never find me in
here
you fool you stupid idiot
you dumb well there's got to be a gen
pipe around here somewhere good thing
that thing is gone forever and I'll
never have to worry about that thing
bothering me ever again
anyway what was I doing gen pipe
Sergeant pipe around here is this gen
pipe this looks like a gent pipe well I
don't have an icon on my
eyes and I don't know what it looks like
wait a minute what about the guy that
was having a bad day did he have a gen
pipe stuck in his heart because if he
had the Gen pipe there then I could rip
it out of his corpse it's true it's so
true
oh now
well this is the jet pipe
way too dark in there
need to get the lights working first I
don't know if that's true
fine whatever I think I saw something to
do with power over here
mayhaps
if I find you I'm gonna rip your face
off I don't think you could what are you
doing
your temperature
there's a swamp thing looking ass
yeah you look at that bench there's a
very interesting bench why don't you
just keep looking at it [ __ ] dumbass
all right whatever I guess I'll just be
on my way with no repercussions is that
food
all right
well
power
let's see if I can find one what if I
take it from the other one I gotta find
a fuse now all right fine
a little rude
ah interesting
no wonder is depressed
I was gonna say no wonder is he
depressed he has no ass so sad for you
I would tell you just how sad it was
once I get my pipe then I'm going to
show you
and you're gonna know what is this peak
interesting
well who needs that when you've got
running
hmm
something else here
I'm running
oh yeah we gotta go all the whoa
kitchen's closed huh what'd you say what
was that about there
hi
is Cthulhu ass
oh God wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait oh man I don't have
many places to go
hey don't Rob
oh God oh God oh God
what did this just glow with I don't
know why this just glowed
oh [ __ ] the hidey holes over there
there's no way he could possibly see me
oh God
now's my chance
foreign
Buffet oh man I'm so hungry
oh God
again with the goopiness
why is there so much goopers hello is
there a fuse in here
cool and a fuse and a cake happy
birthday to me that doesn't make a lot
of sense but whatever sandwich
where
what'd you say
you you coming over this way what's the
deal
oh bad timing his poor timing terrible
timing
he's so dumb God he's so dumb
oh my God he's dumb
I was right under his nose does he even
have a nose probably not
well I got the fuse
I'm probably fine oh
are you dumb
oh my God you're dumb aren't you
hello
hey wait a minute you don't need to do
that
man he got a he got it fast
my huge screen was quick good thing
there's so much food around here I don't
get my health back up in a jiffy
are you gone did you leave
did I scare you off
okay if you cannot be over there because
that's that's actually exactly where I
need to be
uh
dummy
[Music]
Wilson knows our purpose whatever
oh he definitely heard that
door will confound him
brought me in to catalog and secure some
of Joey Drew's more special assets and
places no one will ever find them
sure that sounds completely legal right
anyway I'll be leaving some Clues around
so we can find them later just remember
this nonsense wasn't my idea so here's
my first little hint I finally found a
use for those silly motivational posters
here in the atrium offices they're sure
to make quite an impact oh God I can't
believe I just said that
Atrium posters
impact can't believe I said that you
need to scream impact out loud and then
the poster will give you something
illegal that's what I gathered from all
that you said there
uh nope
put a bit over here nope all right what
about over here nope what about over
here
yes
no I knew it
I wonder why is there so much food that
I just eat period and nothing that I can
actually take with me
maybe because they didn't want people to
be able to heal on the Fly probably
we're playing with fire no question
about it first gen comes in here and
puts thick heavy pipes over everyone's
head must weigh a ton then Joey opens up
the place for tours to the general
public are we really thinking of this
through for Pete's sake Sammy's Music
Department is constantly flooded and
while I was giving a tour last week we
almost lost a whole dang wall when a
valve blew out stupid tour group
applauded thinking it was part of the
show I know Joey's looking out to drum
up some cash lately but this this is
asking for disaster to strike one good
accident and there's going to be a
landslide of trouble Hudson Doyle
I don't know what you mean everything
here is in Ship Shape sorry [ __ ] shape
it's in [ __ ] shape everything's [ __ ]
here it's bad
very bad
it's important
turns out this thing that's glowing is
important
you know mine do you
defend myself
that's always good
all right who wants a woman
let's see the dark puddles are calling
ah good that's what voicemail is for I
think
need any dark puddles calling me
I've got my memories to haunt me
that's what you get
he just [ __ ] died that's all there is
to that yeah end of story that's it good
to know all right and with that
unfortunately
I'm out of time for this episode thank
you everybody so much for watching this
is the beginning of Bendy and the dark
Revival which will continue in short
order very soon but so far so good I
know I was like having fun with it but
honestly like it's it's pretty well put
together and honestly I like the
experience a lot more than I did some of
the pieces of Bendy and the ink machine
not saying it was all bad not saying it
was bad at all but some of them were
just a little bit different but this is
like I love the Bioshock Vibes it's very
very come through strong very coming
through strong just like I'll be coming
through strong in the next video
bye-bye